Please welcome from our L.A. studio Max Greenfield.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Hi!
Hi, Max.
How are you?
I'm so good, how are you?
I'm doing well.
I like what you're wearing,
it's a very Annie Hall vibe, it's great.
Oh, she's a bit of my style icon,
so thank you so much.
Well, me too, she's my style icon as well.
Hair/makeup/wardrobe is a very important step
when you're playing a part.
I agree.
When you get really good people who are doing it
all of a sudden you realize when you get on stage
and you look at yourself in the camera,
you're a totally different person
and then everything else is easy.
Well, it's a funny segue,
but one of the reasons I had brought that up
is because I was watching,
while I was looking at pictures of you and your daughter,
she had done a rainbow eye on you.
And it's funny 'cause my daughter Olive, who's eight,
just did a rainbow eye on herself
and it just looked so cool.
And I love that you're the kind of dad
that will let your daughter do makeup on you.
She loves makeup.
It's Beauty Week on the show this week, right?
Is it!
In fact, you're really kicking it off.
Oh, well this is exciting.
I know they they showed me
a bunch of stuff we have over here.
I thought you could walk me through some of the products
and we could,
we could apply some makeup.
I would love it!
Drew, what am I putting on first?
Why don't we start with the eyes?
And by the way,
this is all actually for your daughter.
So I'm gonna send you a fresh kit for her
so that it's all brand new and perfect.
I'll have that to you later today.
By the way, this stuff looks so nice.
The packaging's very nice.
I don't know what any of it is but it looks great.
Thank you, Max.
We make all the packaging.
I've been doing this business for nearly a decade.
You know what, I'm just gonna have you do it with a finger.
Yeah.
There's a famous makeup artist named Pat McGrath
and she does everything with her finger.
Sure, I love Pat.
Dig your finger in relatively strongly
and then just go right on your eyelids.
No, I knew that.
(audience laughing)
Uh huh, okay, now I want you go
like it's a deodorant on your cheekbones.
Now we're talking.
Yeah, good, perfect.
Now I'm gonna move on to lips.
Find where your middle point is and then work left or right.
Uh huh. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Yes!
(audience cheering)
Max, how do you like making "The Neighborhood"?
It's such a,
a powerful, amazing show
in its format, in its tone,
thematically the storyline--
Well, we have a really wonderful group of writers.
I know, let me,
let's address this.
Maybe we should have done this question first.
I'm literally thinking the same thing.
(audience laughing)
We're just really happy to be back
for a season (giggling).
You really like rolled through the question,
then I go, oh, okay, we're going.
And then I could just disregard what's happening
which may have been the move.
Okay, I'm gonna switch questions.
I will simply answer it with this.
We have an incredible, incredible group of people
on that show.
From Jim Reynolds who created the show
who was on "Big Bang Theory" forever,
Cedric the Entertainer who really
is so much more than just an actor on the show.
He's a producer on the show and really crafts every story
and makes sure that the Butler family
is represented in an organic, authentic way.
Tichina Arnold who has been on TV forever and is probably
the most talented sitcom actress I've ever worked with.
Everyone on the show from top to bottom.
Beth Behrs who plays my wife who I love.
Marcel Spears, Sheaun McKinney,
it's just a great, great group.
Max, may I ask,
how do you feel when your daughter is doing makeup on you?
What goes through your mind?
She's gotten really good at makeup.
She'll come out,
she'll do it in the morning where she has a half hour
between breakfast and her Zoom school,
and then she'll be like
"Check out what I just did."
And we'll go,
"You can't be on your Zoom for school
"with a full face of makeup.
"Having said that,
"you did a really good job and we're very proud of you.
"But you need to take it off."
Seems like you're exactly what a female needs.
You're fun, you're empowering,
(Max laughing)
your humorous, you're playful.
You really are the complete package and--
Yeah, my wife, my wife's somewhere just going like this.
How did you guys meet, may I ask?
We, god almighty,
we met in 2003
and it was just like out at a club.
I love it!
Yeah, well I usually was never allowed
into those clubs or bars,
and I finally got into one and I was like
"I got to find something in here."
But also, Max,
I think you're gonna give a little delusion to women
that they think if they're gonna go to a club
and meet a man like you,
I think you're gonna give women a lot of hope.
No, no, no, no, no.
One, you're me too much credit,
and two, I've met a woman who has just really,
through many different techniques,
changed me in a lot of different ways.
Well, Max,
I am just thrilled to be hanging out with you today.
What a great way to kick off this week with a man who is fun
and good to the women in his life.
I think that is important for Beauty Week.
Well, I appreciate it and I'm so happy to be here
and to meet and sit with you
and this has really been special and great.
And obviously rewarding.
Thank you, Max Greenfield.
The season premiere of "The Neighborhood" is tonight on CBS
and airs Mondays eight/seven central.
Thank you, Max, again, so much for being here.
(upbeat music)